[Music]
hello my name is David silver and I am
the self-driving car team lead at
Udacity self-driving cars are at an
amazing moment right now where thousands
of jobs are opening up and we have
dozens of hiring partners who are really
excited about hiring graduates out of
this program onto their autonomous
vehicle teams Udacity involves
project-based learning so you'll be
building projects that we've designed in
conjunction with companies at the
leading edge of the autonomous vehicle
industry in the first term you'll build
projects on deep learning and computer
vision for example you'll build a
behavioral cloning project where you
drive a car yourself in a simulator kind
of like in a video game and then you use
data from your own driving in the
simulator to train a neural network to
drive that car for you this is the type
of project the cutting-edge Silicon
Valley startups are working on right now
and it puts you at the forefront of the
deep learning an autonomous vehicle
industry you'll also build a project to
detect and track vehicles in a video
stream just like real autonomous
vehicles have to do out on the highway
in term two you'll learn about sensor
fusion localization in control this is
hardcore robotics that every
self-driving car engineer needs to know
in order to actuate and move the vehicle
through space in the localization module
you'll build a kidnap vehicle project
which takes a vehicle that's lost and
figures out where it is in the world
with the help of sensor readings and a
map this is exactly what real
self-driving cars have to do every time
they turn on in order to figure out
where they are in the world in the
control module you'll build a model
predictive controller which is a really
advanced type of controller that's
actually how most self-driving cars move
through the world and use the steering
wheel throttle and brake to follow a set
of waypoints or a trajectory to get from
one point to the
in term three you'll learn about path
planning you'll have an elective month
and you'll learn about system
integration path planning is really the
brains of a self-driving car it's how
the car figures out how to get from one
point to another as well as how to react
when new obstacles enter the scene I'm
going to give you a sneak preview of how
path planning works and this is
something that nobody has ever seen
before
so get ready path planning involves
three parts
there's prediction which is figuring out
what the other vehicles are going to do
around us
there's behavior which is figuring out
what we want to do now that we know what
the other vehicles are going to do and
there's trajectory planning which is
figuring out how to plan or trajectory
to execute the maneuver that we want to
choose as part of the path planning
module you'll build a path planner that
drives the vehicle in the simulator
it'll maneuver around other vehicles and
traffic and get you from one point to
another as quickly and safely as
possible in the advance deep learning
module which is one option during the
elective month you'll build a semantic
segmentation network semantic
segmentation is a cutting edge topic in
deep learning this is how you take a
video feed and paint each pixel in each
image a different color corresponding to
which class that pixel belongs to for
example you could paint each pixel in an
image as either being part of the road
or not part of the road having this
information tells us where the free
space is that we can drive into the
final month of the program is system
integration this is the most exciting
month in the whole program and it's
where we take all of the different
pieces we've learned and we put them
together and you get to design code that
actually goes on the Udacity
self-driving car and see how well it
runs the vehicle we think of this is an
only at Udacity Opportunity and it's a
great way to stand out as you apply for
jobs in the field when hiring people for
the autonomous driving team we are
looking for strong computer science
skills especially programming in C++ in
addition for prototypes we're using
MATLAB and we are using Python
scripting and deep learning tools
respectively when preparing for the
interview the applicants should brush up
their programming skills secondly they
should think how their experience and
education fits to the job some
applicants are surprised to hear
questions how does an autonomous system
works and so on and people should
prepare that in advance should have an
understanding what's going on in that
field and also what Mercedes has already
achieved in that field we have lots of
interns and we are happy to train people
to get the right skills and get
experience in the field
I think the nanodegree is a great thing
to get the right experience in that
field so if you have already a really
solid foundation in computer science for
example and you have successfully
achieved the nanodegree you are a pretty
good candidate for if you want to shape
the future for also namaskar and
mercedes-benz apply we are so excited to
share this program with you and we can't
wait for you to get started there are so
many jobs in this field and so many
employers looking for talent apply now
and become a self-driving car engineer
with Udacity
[Music]